la santé mentale c'est juste une
histoire de volonté tu es triste arrête
rien à fout de ta dépression dire à
quelqu'un qui fait une dépression de se
bouger c'est à peu près aussi efficace
que de dire
et est-ce que vous iriez dire à
quelqu'un qui a une tumeur
arrête ça c'est pour la dépression mais
pour le reste c'est exactement la même
chose quand on parle de maladie mentale
on parle de maladie donc ni un truc
qu'on a décidé d'avoir ni un truc dont
on peut décider de guérir comme ça alors
attention ça veut pas dire qu'on peut
rien faire absolument et qu'il faut se
résigner ça se soigne mais pas tout seul
et c'est pas une question de volonté